it's time for a deep dive number five
Warren Buffett the brutal drop in oil
prices caught even the savviest
investors flat-footed including arguably
the most seasoned of all the chairman
and CEO Berkshire Hathaway was thrilled
with stakes in Exxon and Suncor and is
Burlington Northern Railway serving the
North Dakota Bakken oil shale when oil
traded above $100 a barrel it was good
but with oil prices cut in half it's
almost like there's a Keystone pipeline
open Bloomberg reporter Noah boo hire
covers Buffett and Berkshire and he
joins us now Noah thanks for coming on
the program
so even Warren Buffett was unprepared
for this big drop in oil yeah I think
you know one of the really interesting
things to be said here is that Berkshire
Hathaway his company has gotten so big
that if you look across it there are a
number of ways that it's gonna be
affected by these lower oil prices so
some of the things you said in the intro
he's got his railroad BNSF they've
benefited hugely from the onshore oil
production in places like North Dakota
and it's a it's a real question if oil
stays at this level what that's gonna do
to volumes on the railroad you also
mentioned some of his stock picks about
two years ago maybe a little less he he
bought about 3.7 billion dollars worth
of Exxon stock that's obviously been
pretty challenged here in the last
little stretch and there are a number of
other ways that it's that it's affected
Berkshire let me ask you first of all
about the railroad and the idea is it
just conspiracy theorists who think that
Warren Buffett was one big man standing
in the way of the Keystone pipeline
because it seems when you look at you
know in a word in a word yes it is it's
so much fun yeah but no but but you know
what's what's what's super interesting
about this and I get I get emails from
readers all the time talking about this
what I find interesting is that he said
publicly a number of times that he would
support the pipeline what what what I
think the more interesting quality
public lis is less important than what
he says behind closed
right at the white house that that that
maybe but what's what I think the more
interesting point here is you know just
when that pipeline gets filled or if it
gets built what that is going to do to
the crude by rail volumes that are that
are going at BNSF that's that's an
interesting question and it certainly
remains to be seen what what the answer
is what's the biggest hit - I mean is it
Exxon and Suncor or is BNSF the biggest
problem here because they make so much
money
shipping this stuff well in a you know
when it comes down to dollars and cents
it's it's probably a little bit too
early to say we certainly know the
financial impact when his stock picks go
down because that's pretty transparent
it's a lot harder to tell what the
impact is going to be on the railroad we
don't know yet what you know the volumes
are going to be frankly we don't even
have that greater transparency into
BNSF's margins on on those real oil cars
that they're shipping oh it's a good
point and obviously even with the price
drop the wells that are running are
going to continue to run and what they
pull out of the ground they're gonna
continue to send by rail for now right
exactly exactly and that's a great point
and you know one of the things that my
colleague Tom Black and I pointed out in
our article this week is that BNSF had
huge congestion problems in the on its
northern line last year and that was a
combination of things there was a huge
grain crop there was a lot of oil being
ship and they just got totally gummed up
and in response to that they've been
spending really heavily to expand
capacity and the question now is can
they dial any of that spending back to
accommodate a change in volume on their
railroad or not for now they've said
very publicly that they don't plan to do
that and that they're gonna keep going
ahead with with their spending plan